In House of the Dragon Episode 3, the king
kills a stag, the princess kills a boar, and
the prince kills a crab.. feeder.
There’s a battle, and a party, and no one
has fun except for this pug.
So what happens, and what does it mean?
This video has no spoilers beyond Hot D Episode
3.
The episode starts about three years after
the previous episode.
King Viserys has married Alicent Hightower,
they’ve had a baby named Aegon, and and
Alicent is pregnant with another child.
To celebrate Aegon’s second birthday, they
hold a royal hunt.
We saw a royal hunt in the original Game of
Thrones show – and Thrones author George
Martin said this was his “least favorite
scene in the entire show”.
Because this hunt is just four dudes walking
in the woods.
George said a royal hunt should be a big event
with a hundred dudes, and tents and dogs and
horns.
So the hunt in Hot D is much closer to the
author’s vision – with tents and dogs
and horns.
They hunt in the kingswood, which is a forest
near King’s Landing where only the king
is allowed to hunt animals.
Last episode mentioned a poacher who was “brought
to justice” for the crime of hunting here.
So the hunt is like a big festival, with lots
of food and guests.
Viserys wants everyone to just have fun and
celebrate.
But the lords have political agendas.
Hobert Hightower is the Lord of Oldtown, and
he’s the older brother of Otto Hightower,
the Hand of the King.
The Hightowers want King Viserys to make Alicent
Hightower’s son Aegon heir to the Throne
– instead of Rhaenyra, who Viserys earlier
named as heir.
Cause if Otto’s grandson becomes king, that
could make the Hightowers more powerful.
Previously, it seemed like Otto was motivated
by his own ambition.
But now we see Hobert pressuring him and telling
him what to do.
Last episode, Corlys talked about “second
sons”, how younger brothers are overshadowed
by their older brother, and have to fight
for a place in the world.
We see that dynamic in Hobert and Otto, and
in Corlys and Vaemond, and in Viserys and
Daemon – lots of brother stuff this episode.
We meet Jason Lannister, and his twin brother
Tyland Lannister.
These guys are ancestors of Cersei, Jaime
and Tyrion Lannister.
Jason is the Lord of Casterly Rock.
And Tyland is now on Viserys’ council as
master of ships, to replace Corlys.
The books say that Viserys chose Tyland to
be master of ships because the Lannisters
supported Viserys back at the Harrenhal council.
Jason and Tyland are both played by actor
Jefferson Hall – who once played Ser Hugh
in Game of Thrones Season 1.
>You might not remember Hugh cause he didn’t
last very long.
Lord Lyonel Strong brings his sons, Larys
and Harwin.
Harwin is said to be the strongest knight
in the realm, and has the nickname “Breakbones”.
Larys is called the Clubfoot, because he has
a deformed foot, and has trouble walking.
So instead of joining the hunt, he sits with
the ladies, and listens quietly.
The official website says Larys is “ingenious”
but “underestimated”.
The name Larys sounds like Varys, and Varys
is also a man who listens, and knows the value
of information.
Princess Rhaenyra reads in the godswood, making
a minstrel play the same song over and over
like an iPod on repeat.
The minstrel’s name is Samwell, which might
be a reference to Casablanca, when a musician
called Sam has to keep playing the same song.
Rhaenyra’s song, and Rhaenyra’s book,
are about Nymeria, the ancient eastern princess
who sailed across the sea to escape the dragonlords.
Like Nymeria, Rhaenyra dreams of freedom and
escape.
In Episode 1, we saw Rhaenyra and Alicent
here when they were best friends.
But now Rhaenyra is cold and distant to Alicent
– she still feels angry and betrayed that
her friend suddenly became her step-mum and
her queen.
Rhaenyra tells the minstrel to stay, but Alicent
tells him to leave – and the minstrel obeys
Alicent, not Rhaenyra – cause Queen Alicent
now outranks Princess Rhaenyra.
Rhaenyra hates that she’s been replaced
by Alicent, so she refuses Alicent’s attempts
to reconnect.
On the road, Alicent says that her baby’s
birth was quick and easy – and then there’s
an awkward pause, cause everyone’s reminded
of Rhaenyra’ mum Aemma, who died in childbirth
in Episode 1.
At the hunting camp, everyone cheers for baby
Aegon.
Aegon’s granduncle, Hobert Hightower, calls
Aegon “Second of His Name”, and “His
Grace”, which is what you would say if Aegon
was king – even though officially Rhaenyra
is heir to the Throne.
Many lords want a male ruler, not a woman.
So while everyone cheers Aegon, Rhaenyra sits
alone and ignored.
We hear that Lady Johanna Swann was abducted
in the Stepstones.
Cause the Stepstones are occupied by the Triarchy,
the eastern alliance led by the Crabfeeder.
The books say that the Triarchy impose heavy
taxes on ships passing through the Stepstones
trade routes.
And they don’t just take money.
The Triarchy kidnap people and sell them into
sex slavery in the city of Lys.
Johanna Swann was the fifteen year old niece
of a lord, and after being kidnapped she became
a famous courtesan in Lys, and eventually
was the ruler of the city, “known as the
Black Swan”.
We meet Ceira Lannister, the mother of Jason
and Tyland.
And we meet Lady Joselyn of House Redwyne
– an ancestor of the Queen of Thorns.
Joselyn criticises King Viserys, so Rhaenyra
insults Joselyn.
It’s funny, but it’s probably not smart.
If Rhaenyra wants to rule, she needs allies,
and insulting powerful people is not gonna
help.
Despite being heir to the Throne, Rhaenyra
isn’t acting like a politician – she’s
more like a grumpy teenager.
While Alicent acts more diplomatically – she
behaves like a queen.
Jason Lannister tries to flirt with Rhaenyra
– cause Rhaenyra is now of an age to be
married, and as a royal princess, everyone
wants her.
Jason tries to impress Rhaenyra by bragging
about his wealth – the Lannisters are the
second richest family in the realm, after
the Velaryons.
Jason says that he’s got a really big penis.
I mean a really big castle – Casterly Rock
is taller than the Hightower and taller than
the Wall.
In the books, it’s a mountain with tunnels
and rooms carved into it – though when we
saw Casterly Rock in Game of Thrones it was..
not as impressive.
Jason says that he could build a Dragonpit,
so if Rhaenyra marries him she could keep
dragons at Casterly Rock.
This is not the first time Lannisters have
tried to get dragons.
The old king Jaehaerys, had a sister called
Rhaena.
Rhaena and her dragon Dreamfyre stayed with
the Lannisters for a while.
And the Lannisters tried to convince Rhaena
to give the Lannisters dragon eggs, or to
marry a Lannister so that their children could
have Targaryen dragon blood.
Cause “With dragonriders of their own, the
Lannisters” could be as powerful as the
Targaryens.
Many of the great houses were kings before
the Targaryens took over.
So all the proud lords are envious of Targaryen
dragon power.
Rhaenyra is angry that Viserys wants to marry
her off.
She doesn’t want to be sent away to live
with some husband, and she doesn’t want
Viserys to disinherit her and give the Throne
to Aegon instead.
Viserys handles his unhappy daughter by shouting
at her at a public political event, which
is a terrible idea.
And Rhaenyra rides away, like Princess Nymeria
fleeing the dragonlords.
Otto says there’s been a sighting of a white
hart, a deer with a rare pale colour.
In Westeros, and in real mythology, a white
hart is seen as a rare blessing from the gods,
and a symbol of royalty.
If they catch this white hart on baby Aegon’s
birthday, it could be seen as a sign that
Aegon should be the heir to the Throne.
Otto admits that he doesn’t normally believe
in “signs and portents” – but he will
pretend to believe any old crap if it means
his grandson becomes king.
Jason Lannister gives Viserys a fancy spear
to honour Aegon.
Gifts are a way to try to win political favours
from kings.
Jason mentions the Golden Gallery, which is
a place in Casterly Rock with “gilded ornaments
and walls”, it sounds like the Palace of
Versailles or someplace.
Jason says he expects Aegon to become heir
instead of Rhaenyra, so Viserys drunkenly
shit talks and teases the Lannister to put
him in his place.
Like how King Robert made fun of Lancel Lannister
in Game of Thrones.
King Robert and King Viserys are both charismatic
characters who suck at being king and use
alcohol to cope while terrible conflicts rise
up around them.
Otto tells Viserys that he should marry Rhaenyra
to Aegon.
Viserys laughs at the absurdity of marrying
his daughter to her two-year-old half-brother.
But the age gap between Rhaenyra and Aegon
is less than the gap between Viserys and his
wife Alicent.
And the Targaryens have a long tradition of
marrying their siblings – Viserys’ parents
were siblings, and his grandparents were siblings.
So since Rhaenyra and Aegon are only half-siblings,
<this would be one of the less incestuous
Targaryen royal marriages.
Marrying a Targaryen would prevent other families
from potentially getting dragons.
And a Rhaenyra-Aegon marriage could prevent
any potential conflict between the two for
the Throne.
But Viserys is sick of the “fucking politicking”,
and returns to his wine.
The king is surrounded by people, but is very
alone and stressed.
Viserys is now missing two fingers – his
finger was cut on the Throne in Episode 1,
and was rotting in Episode 2 – now the infected
fingers have been amputated.
The king is literally falling apart, disintegrating
under the weight of his crown.
Lord Lyonel Strong says Viserys is not first
Targaryen king to have trouble with his daughter.
The previous king Jaehaerys had constant problems
with his daughters – Alyssa was a wild tomboy,
Daella was a scaredy-cat, Saera ran off to
a brothel, Viserra was a narcissist.
Lyonel says rebellious Targaryen girls are
“tradition”.
Of course, if every generation of Targaryen
women struggles against the political system,
that might be a sign that it’s the system
that’s the problem, not the women.
They discuss a husband for Rhaenyra, and Viserys
expects Lyonel to say that Rhaenyra should
marry his son Harwin.
But turns out Lyonel is the one guy who doesn’t
recommend his own family’s interests.
Lyonel says Rhaenyra should marry Laenor Velaryon.
Laenor is the son of Corlys Velaryon and Rhaenys
Targaryen – heir to the rich House Velaryon.
Marrying Laenor could finally fix the tension
between the Targaryens and Velaryons – after
Viserys rejected Laena Velaryon, and Rhaenys
was rejected at the Harrenhal Council.
Viserys seems to appreciate that Lyonel gives
unbiased advice, but he also is too wasted
to walk in a straight line.
So Rhaenyra runs off to the woods, and she’s
followed by her sworn protector, Criston Cole.
Rhaenyra and Criston have become close over
the last few years.
Rhaenyra complains about being married off,
about not having a choice, and being powerless.
But Criston reminds her she’s a princess
and her life is way better than most peoples
lives in this medieval world.
And Rhaenyra is not powerless – by choosing
Criston for the Kingsguard, Rhaenyra changed
Criston’s life for the better.
As a lower class person, Criston can give
Rhaenyra the perspective of someone less privileged
than her.
Rhaenyra insists on hanging in the woods instead
of returning to camp.
And they get attacked by a boar.
Criston wounds the animal, and then Rhaenyra
brutally stabs it to death, unleashing her
emotions through violence.
Rhaenyra is full of suppressed anger at her
father, and pain from Alicent’s betrayal,
and she lets it all out on this animal.
Rhaenyra said earlier that dying boars squeal
like children – and then the child Aegon
made a sound.
So now when Rhaenyra kills this squealing
boar, maybe she imagines stabbing Aegon, the
baby that threatens to replace her as heir.
Viserys tells Alicent about his dreams.
Many Targaryens have prophetic dreams of the
future.
Like, Daenys Targaryen dreamed about the Doom
of Valyria before it happened – that’s
how the Targaryens escaped the Doom and came
to Westeros.
Daenys wrote a book of her visions called
Signs and Portents – which is the same phrase
Otto uses to describe the white hart.
We know that Viserys once dreamed that he
would have a son and that son would king.
But when Aemma and her son died, Viserys lost
faith in this dream.
He gave up on having a son, and so he named
Rhaenyra his heir.
But now that Viserys finally has a son, Aegon,
he’s doubting himself again.
Maybe his dream of a son was right after all,
and Aegon should be the heir, not Rhaenyra.
The white hart is part of his doubt – if
they find the white hart on Aegon’s birthday,
that sign might convince Viserys that Aegon
should be heir.
So Viserys is full of doubt and guilt and
grief, which is similar to other Targaryen
dreamers.
In The Hedge Knight prequel story, Daeron
Targaryen feels tortured by his dreams, and
uses alcohol to try to escape them to a dreamless
sleep.
Daeron’s brother Aemon says dreams killed
his brothers, every one.
Alicent looks concerned that her husband and
king is drunkenly rambling about using dreams
to decide the future of the realm and of her
son.
In the morning, they find a deer, but it’s
not the white hart – it’s just a normal
brown deer.
So Viserys feels relieved – there was no
special omen on Aegon’s birthday, so maybe
Viserys made the right choice after all and
Rhaenyra should be the heir.
Viserys is expected to kill this deer, even
though he didn’t hunt it down, and he doesn’t
really want to kill it.
This is similar to how Viserys had his wife
Aemma killed – she also was held down and
helpless, sacrificed reluctantly by Viserys.
It’s the job of a king to sacrifice people
for the good of the realm – soldiers in
battle, women in childbirth.
But Viserys’ compassion makes him reluctant
to make these hard decisions, and that’s
why it’s hard for him to be king.
Viserys fails to kill the deer cleanly, and
has to stab it twice.
Which is another bad omen.
It’s like when Theon struggles to kill Rodrik
in Game of Thrones – this violence is ugly
and cold and farcical and makes everybody
look bad.
The deer can represent King Viserys himself
– cause the deer is a strong regal animal,
but it’s also constrained, struggling, pulled
in different directions by these men, just
as Viserys is pulled in different directions
by his lords and their politics.
In Game of Thrones Episode 1, a dead stag
foreshadows the death of King Robert, killed
by a boar – so this dead stag could be foreshadowing
for Viserys.
Meanwhile, Rhaenyra is covered in the blood
of her violence.
Her killing was not some fake ceremonial slaughter,
it was real hot-blooded violence to defend
herself from attack.
And as she looks over the kingswood, the white
hart appears to her.
Just walks right up like some mystical sign
from the gods that Rhaenyra should be the
heir.
Criston draws his sword, but Rhaenyra tells
him not to kill the hart.
This shows that Rhaenyra can be merciful and
peaceful, in contrast to her killing of the
boar.
Not killing the white hart also fits with
the animal’s mythology.
In the Game of Thrones books, Sansa thinks
that in the stories, knights never harm white
harts.
So Rhaenyra plays the role of the gentle heroes
in the stories.
But if Rhaenyra did kill the white hart and
showed everyone back at camp, that might’ve
convinced people to support her as heir.
Her choice not to kill the hart might represent
Rhaenyra choosing not to go for the Throne.
So just like the dreams and prophecies, this
mystical sign is ambiguous – it’s up to
the characters and the viewers to decide what
this sign means.
Rhaenyra brings the boar back to camp, so
she still gets to prove herself to everyone.
Jason Lannister is grossed out, but Harwin
Strong is visibly into it.
Back at the Red Keep, Otto speaks with his
daughter Alicent.
They’re quite formal and distant with each
other – Otto calls Alicent “Your Grace”,
which suggests that Otto sees Alicent more
as a political asset than as his daughter.
Otto says that her son Aegon will inherit
the Throne, because he’s male,.
Alicent says Rhaenyra is the heir, but Otto
tells her to convince Viserys to name Aegon
heir.
Alicent speaks with Viserys, and tells him
that Rhaenyra will marry if she thinks it’s
her choice to marry – which sounds a bit
manipulative, but it also shows that Alicent
understands Rhaenyra’s feelings and wants
her to be happy.
Alicent learns that the war in the Stepstones
is going badly.
Viserys doesn’t want to help Daemon and
Corlys, because Daemon and Corlys started
this war against Viserys’ wishes – he
doesn’t want to look weak.
But Alicent says Viserys should do what’s
best for the realm, regardless of his personal
feelings.
Which is what a king should do.
And Alicent doesn’t bring up making Aegon
heir like Otto told her to – so Alicent
doesn’t just go along with her father’s
plots, she advocates for the greater good
instead – maybe Alicent is a good queen.
This is the first episode where we don’t
see Alicent picking at her fingernails.
She has become more confident.
But her exact goals and plans are not yet
clear.
Viserys listens to Alicent, and sends reinforcements
to help Daemon and the Velaryons.
Viserys and Rhaenyra argue some more about
Rhaenyra getting married.
Viserys admits that he married Alicent out
of selfish desire, not political advantage.
So he says he’ll let Rhaenyra choose who
she wants to marry.
And Viserys swears that he won’t replace
Rhaenyra as heir.
So Viserys affirms his support for Rhaenyra..
privately, but many of the lords still see
Aegon as heir.
And if Rhaenyra marries for desire instead
of for political advantage, she might not
have the support she needs to claim the Throne
when Viserys dies.
While the royalty are plotting and feasting,
on the Stepstones, men are fighting for their
lives.
The Velaryons and Prince Daemon are at war
against the Triarchy, led by the Crabfeeder.
And the war is going badly for the Westerosi.
We see Daemon attacking the Triarchy with
his dragon Caraxes, but the Triarchy learn
to avoid the dragons by hiding in caves.
These guerrilla tactics are similar to how
the Dornish successfully resisted Aegon’s
Conquest.
We see Daemon’s dragon stomp on one of his
own men, which shows that Daemon doesn’t
really care who he kills.
And shows that dragons are not precise weapons.
When dragons go to war, there’s collateral
damage, and ordinary people get killed.
Daemon gets shot with an arrow, and his dragon
Caraxes cries out as though in pain.
The books say there’s a mysterious bond
between dragon and dragonrider, like some
psychic connection that lets dragons feel
what their riders feel.
The Starks and their direwolves have a similar
connection in the books.
So Daemon and Caraxes cause some havok, but
they fail to find the Crabfeeder.
The Velaryons are led by Lord Corlys Velaryon.
We also meet Corlys’ younger brother Vaemond
Velaryon, a commander in their navy.
Vaemond seems to have a combative relationship
with his brother – like Viserys and Daemon,
and Hobert and Otto.
Laenor Velaryon is the son of Corlys and Rhaenys.
He seems to have had a big growth spurt since
we saw him in Episode 1.
And this guy is Ser Joffrey Lonmouth.
He’s called the Knight of Kisses, because
the heraldry of House Lonmouth has red lips
and skulls.
The Velaryons are outnumbered, they’re running
out of food, they fear they’ll be eaten
by the crabs.
But then Daemon finds out that his brother
Viserys sent reinforcements to help them – which
you’d think would be good news.
But Daemon gets so angry that he beats up
the messenger.
Cause as Viserys said, Daemon would rather
die than accept help from his big brother.
Daemon is here to prove himself, to show that
he can win by his own strength.
So before Viserys’ reinforcements arrive,
Daemon leads a suicidally dangerous attack.
The plan is for Daemon to lure the Crabfeeder
from his caves.
So Daemon goes alone, and he pretends to surrender,
by waving a white flag.
Only to betray the Triarchy and attack them
anyway.
It’s like in Game of Thrones when Ramsay
gets Theon to use a peace banner to get some
ironborn to surrender, but Ramsay betrays
the ironborn and kills them anyway.
This is another example of Daemon breaking
rules to get what he wants.
Daemon single-handedy kills like a dozen dudes,
dodges arrows, does a barrel roll, and somehow
doesn’t die.
And just when he seems doomed, he’s saved
by Laenor Velaryon, on his dragon Seasmoke.
So they didn’t mention it til now, but Laenor
has a dragon.
Because Laenor has Targaryen dragon blood,
through his mother Rhaenys Targaryen.
Rhaenys Targaryen herself also has a dragon,
called Meleys, the Red Queen.
The other dragonriders currently are Rhaenyra,
with the yellow dragon Syrax.
And Daemon with the red dragon Caraxes.
There are also a bunch of other dragons around
that currently don’t have riders – like
Vermithor, the Bronze Fury, which was the
dragon of old King Jaehaerys.
Silverwing was the dragon of Jaehaerys’
wife Alysanne.
Dreamfyre was Rhaena Targaryen’s dragon.
And old Vhagar is on the east coast somewhere.
Plus there are probably a bunch more hatchlings
and eggs on Dragonstone.
We’ll see many more dragons later in the
story.
Seasmoke is a silvery grey dragon.
And he’s a young dragon, fast and nimble
in flight.
He and Laenor burn the Triarchy from the sky,
while the Velaryons attack on the ground,
led by Lord Corlys, and by Vaemond.
Daemon goes after the Crabfeeder, and finally
kills the crab.
In the book, Daemon cuts off the Crabfeeder’s
head, but in the show he butchers him off-screen.
Daemon gets covered in the Crabfeeder’s
blood, which might be a bad idea.
Cause according to behind-the-scenes info,
the Crabfeeder had greyscale, a disease that
can be highly contagious.. and deadly.
So is Daemon gonna get infected and turn into
a stone man?
In the Game of Thrones show, greyscale can
be cured – Jorah Mormont and Shireen Baratheon
are both cured of greyscale.
In the books, it’s different.
The books say there are different forms of
greyscale.
The swift “grey plague” is deadly.
But there’s a different form of the disease
that affects children, and it gives them stony
grey skin but it doesn’t kill, and it’s
not contagious.
So maybe Crabfeeder had a form of greyscale
that isn’t contagious, so Daemon is safe.
There is also an idea in the books that Targaryens
are immune to diseases – that the blood
of the dragon has “a purifying fire” that
saves Targaryens from getting sick.
Daenerys Targaryen believes this, and she
never gets sick, even when she visits disease
victims in the books.
But some other Targaryens do die of disease.
King Daeron Targaryen the Second and his grandkids
die of a plague.
And Maegelle Targaryen dies of greyscale.
So not all Targaryens are immune to disease,
but maybe some are.
There are hints that it’s only Targaryens
who have dragons who don’t get sick – King
Daeron and Maegelle don’t have dragons.
But Daenerys and Daemon do have dragons.
So maybe Daemon is immune.
That said, Crabfeeder’s greyscale is not
in the books, it’s never actually mentioned
in this show, and it sounds like the showrunners
just added it to make the Crabfeeder look
scary.
The point is, Daemon’s reckless violence
wins him victory.
His blood-soaked killing is similar to Rhaenyra’s
violence with the boar.
While King Viserys awkwardly slaughters a
defenceless deer, Rhaenyra and Daemon win
real victories against real enemies.
The showrunners say these characters are “reborn”,
finding new strength and purpose, forged stronger
by fire and blood.
If you want to know more about when the Lannisters
tried to get dragons from Rhaena Targaryen,
or about King Jaehaerys’ rebellious daughters,
the full story is told in Fire & Blood.
You can get Fire & Blood on audiobook for
free right now at audible.com/asx.
Sign up for a Premium Plus trial membership,
and you get an audiobook to keep, even if
you cancel the trial.
You can get any Game of Thrones book, or Lord
of the Rings, or Dune.
Membership also includes unlimited access
to thousands of audiobooks and shows in the
Audible Plus Catalog.
Sign up at audible.com/asx, or text asx to
500-500.
Thanks for watching.
Please like and subscribe.
You might also like to sign up to the Alt
Shift X audio feed, where you can get all
of these videos as podcast episodes – so
you can listen to them on Spotify or your
podcast app.
Thanks to the Patrons, including Doctor Folter,
BroskiBakes, Zoe Sarullo, Caio Alves, Kyle
Brigman, and Rogue Prince.
Cheers.